eh bien
bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
spécial champion du monde prennent games
ce soir avec bien entendu stéphane
laborde m en soirée loi aujourd'hui on
s'attendait à une réaction de kasparov
elle a failli avoir lieu on va dire
qu'il ya quand même essayer de jouer à
fond cette fois mes chroniques a encore
une fois dévié et poussé kasparov dans
une ouverture qui n'avait pas préparé
effectivement chronique a changé une
fois de plus enfin grosse constatation
de cette partie stéphane c'est quand
même un kasparov atig et qui est arrivé
dans l'échiquier effectivement fatigué
dans la mesure où il était mal rasé
extrêmement tout pâle très très fatiguée
garry kasparov et en plus quand vladimir
kramnik donc l'a surpris en jouant cette
fameuse espagnol fous ces cinq
complètement inattendu complètement
inattendu et encore une fois caspar
désarçonné et on a pu voir aujourd'hui à
ses mimiques qu'il avait l'air vraiment
perdu et mal dans sa tête ça vous
pourrez le revoir dans les highlights
évidemment mais gary kasparov
aujourd'hui avait l'air complètement
dépité complètement déprimé et en fait
c'était du bluff puisque nous avons eu
la réponse à la conférence de presse il
aurait donc il avait l'air complètement
livide complètement cuit alors qu en
fait pas du tout c'est simplement parce
qu'il avait oublié un coup dans sa
préparation
bon alors on va voir la partie c'était
fabuleux parce qu'ils sont ils ont joué
vingt coups à toute vitesse
ouais en suite kasparov a réfléchi
longtemps et a joué apparemment un
mauvais coup mais la voilà on voit
kasparov ici réfléchir à ce moment là
justement au moment où il sait qu'il a
oublié probablement ce qu'on fait c'est
ce qu'il a dit en conférence de presse
mais cramique a rétorqué que non
ouais alors ça le force de presse était
grandiose ouais il faut voir la
conférence de presse parce que la cram
midi n'ont de toute façon le coup que tu
as soi-disant oublier le coup de tours à
en fait rien du tout enfin donc voilà on
kasparov extrêmement fatigué là qui
clignent des yeux extrêmement régulière
mais qu il était abattu dans cette
partie avec un sport complètement battu
il tournait la tête dans tous les sens
il gigotait il gesticule et à la c'était
c'était assez c'était dur à le voir dans
cet état là garry kasparov
voilà là
c'est à dire que et on a eu cette même
pendant cinq minutes en téléphone ah oui
il ya aussi la pose comment sans me
regarder les couilles
est ce qu'il regrette à ce moment là
vraiment n'avoir joué ce coup est ce que
c'est du bluff
il est le coût du stylo s'il ya un mois
il a pris son stylo et de la jeter sur
sa feuille de partie ouais encore là
c'est en un prochain du but et kasparov
est au bord du gouffre il est très très
fatiguée garry kasparov il n'en peut
plus il a dû travailler comme un fou
pour réfuter la berlinoise pour essayer
de passer ce mur de berlin pas réussi à
ré kasparov
enfin il a peut-être trouvé quelque
chose mais en tout cas chronique m'a pas
laissé la possibilité de le montrer
puisqu'il a joué cette fameuse espagnol
oui voilà kasparov vraiment ne s'en sort
pas il a plus que deux fois les blancs
c'est quasiment impossible moines ont
remonté deux points comme ça à la
commande mais ça justement je pense que
ce sera l'analyse d'après la partie
puisque effectivement on fera un bilan
sur ce match en fin d'émission sur la
situation actuelle
mais effectivement ça fait dur pour
gagner alors on va tout de suite
commencé la partie
la voilà et des jolis c'est une partie
le 4 e 5 qu'avait dit f3 kessé si donc
là on croit qu'on va revoir la
berlinoise après foulée 5 de kasparov
est-ce qu'on s'attend à ce que crâne il
joue le coup cavalière 6 voilà du
déjà-vu puisque chronique a tenu mais
alors sans aucun problème
les quatre premiers de 4 milliards et
3,3 fois trois fois il a tenu facile
mais non chronique joue à six dont qui
dévie est un autre jour il retourne à
l'espagnol classique on peut supposer
que vladimir kramnik après avoir vu
kasparov dans lé talent évident dans
lequel il se trouve et c'est à dire
l'état extrêmement fatigué il a dû se
dire oh vous l'a dit mir et bien
finalement
kasparov a dû travailler comme un fou
comme un dingue donc je vais surprendre
ouais c'est le silence gardé de lui
poser un maximum de problèmes à 6 c'est
le coup qu'on a vu dans tous les matches
enfin kasparov et un spécialiste de
l'espagnol de toute façon il va sur le
terme d' eric kasparov apparemment ici
fois quatre cavaliers si ce petit rock
donc très connu en donne le pion au 4
mai enfin la sas et d'espagnol avec ali
prend 4 d2 d4
on se rappelle tous enfin tous ceux qui
l'ont vu en tout cas des superbes
victoires de garry kasparov contre à
nantes dans cette position c'était dans
le match alors 95 b5 four b3 la frousse
et 5 c
et kramnik c'est ce qui surprend puisque
d'habitude on joue plutôt le kung fu en
hausse est juste devant le roi la case
ici voilà que tu montres en rouge juste
devant le roi mais la chronique des
vignes et joue le coup pousser cinq
variantes beaucoup plus sauvage et ils
vont répéter à partir de là une partie
qui avait joué shirov contre eux et
contre eux kasparov en fait voilà
c'était kasparov blanc contre shirov
noir donc évidemment kramnik avait
préparé comme un fou puisque quand
kasparov a déjà joué il faut préparer
deux fois plus oui que s'il n'est jamais
joué évidemment mais fou ces cinq c'est
une vente nouvelle et ça a le mérite
quand même de sortir kasparov des
schémas d'espagnol de la fameuse torture
espagnole qu'il connaît très bien
puisqu'il en a gagné un nombre
incalculable notamment contre kharkov
donc la foux ces cinq locaux à la mode
le coup jeunes contrat kasparov
ag oui oui tout à fait voilà qu'est ce
qu'on joue le coup à quatre mêmes alors
là on va en voir suivre une suite de
coups on va les commenter brièvement
parce que les joueurs les gens de jouer
très vite et donc ils ont répété une
partie que kasparov donnait déjà donc
psychologiquement ça pas tellement
d'intérêt
on va prendre a expliqué quand même les
coûts pour montrer les grandes idées à
cap donc évidemment l'idée c'est que ça
menace directement plan b 5
effectivement puisque le pion à 6 pour
l'instant floue et oui parce que sinon
la tour voilà tout reprendre et loire se
réveille
voilà donc deux possibilités soit on
joue tour des mythes qui est l'ancien
coup le coup dit solide on garde le fond
assez vite pour le maintenir
vers la défense du roi notamment faire
le contrôle gaza ça c'est le coup solide
mécanique évidemment il n'est pas là
pour jouer solide en tout cas dans cette
partie des là pour faire peur et garry
kasparov il faut donc foulé cette wii
n'a pas peur hein chronique des trois
normales le fou et en 1h17
il n'y a plus aucune raison de jouer des
cats il faut bloquer ce fou donc on
blinde le point d'eau 4 et l'idée à long
terme pour les blancs c'est soit
d'amener une pièce en d5 soit d'attaqué
des cinq soit d'amener une pièce un f5
les trois possibilités ça se passe sur
quelle planche enfin petit rock pour
cramique kessé trois qualifiés 3 hélas
assez logique le coucou de chez rough le
coach shirov qui avaient l'année à 5
pour échanger le foot des trois c'est
dangereux puisque ça laisse beaucoup de
pions noirs emprise et descend l'ès 2
stéphane puisque après médiation bessan
qui est attaqué deux fois par l'option
étant le cavalier qui les défendent eu
qu'une seule fois oui et le pion aux
arènes qui lui n'est carrément pas
défendu alors qu'ils attaquaient pas
travaillé depuis emprise donc pour garry
kasparov des 5 et 2 5
mais qu'à spa g mi qu'encore une fois
aime bien prendre la paire de fou de
caspar enfin comme d'habitude et l'air
en plus il va prendre la paire de fond
en b3 ça casse fétiche dans ce match tu
reprends b5 à peu près forcément pour
garry kasparov fois deux premiers pas
grand chose et ça a déjà été joué donc
les deux joueurs connaissent très bien
ils sont à peu près sûrs d'eux à ce
moment là qu'elle prend b3 puis on prend
b3 surprend bessin voilà une position
très logique et d'envoi les options au
prix de dessin que cinq ans prise en
compensation qu'est ce qui se passe les
noirs aux prises la paire de faux ils
ont deux fous contre un sol voilà fondé
cette poussée scène ça c'est important
on va le voir surtout dans cette partie
et puis les pions en blanc allèles dames
sont un peu disloqué voilà ils sont très
très beau très moche c'est d'options b2
et b3 à noter évidemment que le coup cac
et prend b5
ce serait de la folie pure tout
simplement parce que ça ouvre sa ou la
colonne b quoi même attention la tour
est en prise à lyon oui oui autant pour
que la tour est en prison il faut que la
folie pure
c'est pour ça que sport d'abord échange
les tours et après il faut prendre
maintenant joue le coup car les prend à
eux cinq qui prend le coup le pion
central ce qui est logique voilà c'est
un c'est un grand principe évidemment
prenez l'option centrale toujours
comprends pas pourquoi on peut pas le
prendre il faut prendre l'option
centrale c'est un vieux principe l'idée
c'est de jouer des trois des cartes ici
stefan wey et de marthe et un centre
compact et solide elle est blonde pour
menace de prendre en compte davantage
besoin de plus ils prennent le centre en
plus c'est gros avantage blanc tout à
fait donc il faut que les gens
réagissent très vite on cramique superbe
sous le coup des cinq boom qui explose
le centre avec toutes les pièces noires
qui contrôle très bien de cases blanches
au centre le x 8 qui ne sont post
contrôler la grande diagonale
le cavalier m6 qui contrôle les cases
blanches c'est maintenant le pion des
singles et bien si me se mêler au combat
au centre donc on donne aussi le tueur
b5
mais ça c'est pas grave puisque là on
est on fait une menace directe menace te
prends le pur 4 complètement distinctes
mais ça c'est encore que tu sais encore
la partie de foot les 5 tout ça c'est la
partie kasparov contre shirov dont les
jets étaient jaunes exactement il a
déviation de vladimir kramnik qui fait
une nouveauté en premier puisque ils
jouent des prend le 4 dans cette
position-là shirov avait joué si je ne
dis pas de bêtises le cou aux 7 elle
était revenue il avait
qu'est-ce qu'il avait finalement après
l'aï perdu il y avait fait nul très
facile finul il y avait une variante de
ce goût là qui est pro b 5 pions 3 ou 4
puis on prend 1,4 et là c'était s'est
ténu de l'eau très vite après ces points
4 il ya eu aucun moyen pour kasparov de
passer dans cette position il
effectivement toujours actions plus
puisqu'il d'adoption l'a contraint sol
quand même chez les jets mais il appert
de fou compenser largement et shirov a
fait nul très facilement dans cette
partie enfin après fou g5 vladimir
kramnik ne joue pas fou au 7 mai je vous
écoute des prend 1,4 relevant le défi
simplement le vin que des filles mais
tout à fait puis on prend 1,4 toujours
très vite kasparov
malgré ça il connaît toujours la
position était tout impôt c'était
superbe d'un programme tout reprend là
on s'attendait non s'attendait pas à
s'intéresser à toutes façons son choc
tellement vite qu'on s'attendait à un
oui les synthés s'attendre à quoi que ce
soit le temps de convois la position il
avait déjà joué les coups donc d4 contre
attaque sur le canal irc 3 wii et l'idée
c'est pour les noirs c'est de mettre la
pression sur le pion aux 403 là qui est
sous la prise du fou à 8 et du cavalier
fils déjà première remarque six
cavaliers bouge on va piquer le pion à
quatre avec lecavalier en contre
attaquant sur le fou j'ai sache
exactement ça ce n'est pas tolérable il
faut donc faire des anicroches tactique
des petites donc fou prend même si cela
fut empreint ces trois là le faut si ces
tapis est attaqué mais là une petite
pointe puisque la willaya un problème je
crois sur quel aider cette série l'a
pris dans ses 3 et après une c3 puisque
cas et 17
il y à une contre pointe ces femmes
bonjour et ses deux peut-être un jour
essaient de tout à fait jouer ses trois
ces deux à s'arrêter dans la tour
attaque la tour la tour de bouger
probablement en c1 et maintenant on
vient reprendront f6 et la position
extrêmement complexe voilà puisque après
qu'il ait procès cinq jeunes y retrouver
plus mon latin sur qui les prend 7,5 il
ya le coutour des mythes
profitant du match du couloir et de la
force momentanée du fiancé 2 on peut
voir par le pion sous peine d'être
maintenant on fait un signe variante
omaha à ses ventes kitty est importante
c'est important mais bon faire les
joueurs connaissaient tous par ailleurs
mais en fait ils ont même pas réfléchi
ils ont joué tempo qui on prend ces
trois tu en prends f6 c'est compliqué
quand même loin et cette partie d'un
très compliqué enfin cette ouverture
très compliqué mais c'est de la
préparation maison des deux côtés
c'est peut-être la première fois qu'on
assiste à sa dans ce match
fou des six normales il faut défendre le
fou et là il prend la tour il faut
prendre un tour puisque sinon une noire
une pièce de plus et après on apprend
mais voilà c'est le moment de faire un
bilan
c'est le moment du bilan pas tout à fait
puisqu'il encore le pion aux quatre ans
prises ouais donc il a joué f3 des
jouets rencontre logiquement là et la
chronique commencé à réfléchir un peu
comme dit que non les cheveux tempo
chronique jouer tempo il a joué le coup
à 7 h 5 très serré et c'est là que ça
voilà c'est là que l'espoir fait
réfléchie très très longtemps
oui exactement alors la voix le bilan
père de fou pour les noirs oui mais
quand même donc tours et deux pions nous
plus pour les blancs ce qui paraît
beaucoup parlé il faut commencer par un
bilan matériel on compte les pions les
blancs non si cela nous rend tous 4 ça
fait deux ans de plus pour les blancs
ouais d'options plus une tour contre de
fou alors stéphane ça veut dire si on
compte le matériel ça fait 7 contre 6,7
me on va bien ouais donc peu différente
âge d'or blanc d'ailleurs qui se dément
pas les noirs peuvent prendre pour
probablement pas espérer gagner
mais d'un côté on voit pas comment les
blancs passe parce que les fous contrôle
énormément de cases à noter évidemment
que tu es que les diagonales pour
s'ouvrir si jamais des diagonales venait
à s'ouvrir les fous commencerait avoir
des chances il suffit de piquer un pion
à rappeler quand même que les noirs peut
ré échanger tous les pions et ensuite
sacrifié un fou contre les pions qui
reste puisque fouet roi contre roy +
tour ça fait nul oui tout à fait
d'ailleurs c'est la singapore attentes
donc ça on le voit oui mais c'est
toujours la menace inhérentes à cette
position
cirque un fou peut toujours se sacrifier
contre deux pions ou un seul c'est
souvent le nombre de pions qui reste
s'il reste plus de piment mais roy et
tout droit il fou tiennent facilement
contre roy est tout autre chose qui est
très important ici comme l'a dit
chronique dans son livre est bien j'aime
bien avoir la peur de fous pourquoi
parce que quand il ya un fou qui est
mauvais ça veut dire que l'autre est bon
ici ça se dément pas effectivement
puisque les pions ici y domine le x 8
c'est clair oui en revanche ça laisse
libre champ aux fous des six qui m'a
collé sur les cases noires où il vaut il
sait mieux se fout oui c'est du gruyère
donc ça c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas
dominer de fouet à la fois prennent pour
des sports alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait un
plan qui semble bon puisqu'il joue
d'abord le coup alors ils jouent h4 ça
c'est indispensable
voilà ce que les noirs menacent eux
mêmes de jouer h théâtre et de fixer
complètement les pions blancs
tout à fait d'accord tout ça joue h4
lui-même l'idée c'est de fixer le pion
sur la case h5 ce fait on peut plus
bouger et ce pion peut s'avérer faible
et la tour pc d'en profiter
par exemple pour passer via la casa 5
pour attaquer ce pion et le gober ça
donnerait trois pieds en avant sa peau
commence à faire beaucoup
c'est le programme ça on veut aller
piquer sauf sur 11,5 on va voir que
travnik a pas beaucoup de coups à jouer
il n'a pas avec les fous c'est difficile
de trouver un plan de travail qui a
décidé de ne rien faire dans cette
partie recettes il centralise et la
casse parfait le coup qu'il atteindra la
gaffe
ouais c'est ce qu'il y a la confiance de
presse mais kramnik dit que sur tora 1
il avait il avait aucun souci
apparemment kasparov aura joué une
partie d'entraînement il avait joué tour
un way et c'était extrêmement difficile
pour les noirs de gagner si on écoute
kasparov lui dis carrément c'était gagné
il dit carrément que ces gagnants alors
l'idée effectivement c'est ça attaque le
x 8
voilà de ce fou doit donc bouger par
exemple en italie c'est pareil tout à
fait payer maintenant tour à savoir la
torah 5
l'attak le pion aux cinq attaques
l'option h5 on peut pas le laisser en h5
s'est passé est logique on peut pas le
laisser prendre il faudrait faut 5
oui et là apparemment gary a dit ouais
j'ai joué cette position gagnant sur
quoi cramique évidemment s'est pas
démonté il
dans un premier temps il n'a rien dit
mais après l'arrivée d'un journaliste
qui a insisté khady bâ lors communique
toujours un truc perdant mais rami qui a
dit non non pas du tout car il peut
parler
moi j'ai joué un truc égal maintenant il
est dit il a dit qu'il aille bien
analyser cette possibilité aussi et que
c'était nul ne voyait pas comment les
bleus pouvaient gagner non plus n'en
irait tout à fait donc ici
kasparov joue le coup qu'il appellera la
faute le court en f2 pourquoi la faute
stéphane et bien parce que kramnik va
jouer le coup deux suivants i les
joueurs rêvent de caisse par fo 17
fauves et 7 qui qui du coup ne perd pas
le plus de temps que si les bleues
noires et blanches aura on un tel que le
fou est scellé blanche de touraine ya un
problème et stéphane il faut cinq ans ce
mois là c'est à dire que maintenant
après le couteau un montage des faux
seins qui est très ennuyeux un peu joué
social puisque le fou n'est ce pas
attaquer la crise sur ces trois là voilà
donc les spurs jouent ces quatre là il a
muselé le foot 17 en enfermant exception
déception qui font une structure anti
fou ouais
et là ça a plongé krainik dans une
réflexion alors qu'il a duré une heure
qui avait pratiquement une heure de
réflexion pendant direct c'était assez
dur a commenté stéphane russie taylor
quelques quelques longueurs mais enfin
ce n'est pas grave mais enfin on a finit
quand même en une heure à comprendre
l'idée de kasparov
l'idée c'est d'abord je place mes pions
contre le fou c'est ce qu'on voit le fou
en rouge est mal placée je mets mon roi
pour défendre des pions bien le roi
garde un oeil sur clan 24 et une fois je
l'amélioré ces petites pièces là je fais
entrer l'artillerie lourde c'est à dire
la tour en 1 puis en a 5 ou en a 7
bref j'ai des castes d'entrée et je vais
aller chatouiller le pion h5 le fou 17
face à mu et garry kasparov ouais voilà
ça c'était son plan sur quoi cram dit
qu'elle jouait super poids 5 contrôler
la casamance les femmes ça s'est vu
contre la casse de l'autre côté on a
l'impression que les autres coups sont
bons aussi
ouais c'est vrai qu'on a on n'a pas tout
voyez patron de considérer le truc c'est
que ça laisse quand même b4 mais sur
quoi chronique dis simplement à kasparov
et bien vas-y gary avancé des pions
voilà on s'est rendu compte si
l'excellent et blanc un poussent leurs
pions et baignoire proposition de leurs
fous pour les attaquer par exemple
poussé trois oui je les pions à avancer
donc à s'affaiblir
mais si on avait dit fou celui tous ces
huit vous séduit celui de c'est pas mal
non plus ils essayent de le remettre aux
six en fait à tout simplement attaquant
les pions qui maintenant n'est plus
protégé et ça oblige les pions à
s'affaiblir tous actuellement fait et
puis on va amener le roi envers nous le
monarque va arriver lui-même
personnellement pour les manger les
pions pour manger les pions donc ça
c'était pas acceptable faut cinq tours
d2 la galerie était très énervé mais
c'est là qu'il nous a fait sa série de
mimiques atroce après 3,2 pouces 1 qu'il
était très ne pouvait plus fou c'est
vite g micro placé pièce c'est bien joué
la menace c'est le coup avec cette
absence stéphane cravic veut ouvrir des
perspectives à s'en fout c'est vite
voilà il veut échanger des pions blancs
et qu'on regarde vers des diagonales
il veut une fois de plus attaqué psion
b3 tout simplement oui en passant le fou
donc ans et 8 puis aux rêves simples
puis en c2 mais pour aller attaquer la
fameuse cible habituelle des plans b 3
way quand même toujours pareil prend la
paire de fouet changé d'âme et attaque
le pion b3 c'est ça tout ça c'est pareil
c'est la formule 2 formule fort cramique
slogans demandant comment va de carrick
a question of the doc tour des 5 contre
attaque s'en faut cinq dons qu'il ya
plus de f 5 m de fond après exactement
faut 6 2 chroniques très logique torah 5
la tour fait
petite pression mais non sur 7 ouais
mais là ça commence à devenir
intéressant ce qui se passe puisque à
venir ça peut être le coureur 3
maintenant que le faux 5 peut plus
bouger parce qu'il achetait incomprise
oui le plan c 3 3 et 4 effectivement
très fort et la chronique joué un joli
coup le seul coup en fait tout simple
mais qui bloque les blancs voilà le coup
puisque donc cette c5
c'est pas mal d'autres qu'est ce qui se
passe et une pointe technique stéphane
puisqu'après tout reprendre ses 5 qui
serait une gaffe
et bien tout simplement pouls des quatre
échecs récupère la tour fou des quatre
échecs
je perds la tour à larache faut des cats
échec pour le tour voilà tout simplement
c'est une pointe assez basique mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire eh bien ça
veut dire qu'après ces 5
eh bien on va de toute façon mettre le
flou en d4 et ça c'est quand même
important
oui d'après le coup de kasparov ici road
3 3 kasparov a joué ça ici bien ils
ramènent souvent après du centre et
après échec foot et qu'après chaque 3d
3d 3 on va voir que kasparov a une
petite pointe pour essayer d'avancer ses
pions
il veut jouer b3 b4 ici il veut jouer
mais quatre puisque l'idée c'est que si
les noirs prennent ce pion évidemment le
foot emprise voilà aura des trois et
cinq ans même chronicles ça y est lui
ravi qu'il a trouvé le plan là il
ouais il veut sortir c'est fou le sis
dans la boîte seulement de sortir oui il
veut changer des pions blancs pour que
son fils respire plus puisque pour
l'instant que tout les cas sont prises
par les pions blancs des quatre décades
donc là pas mal casse par an va secret
propre peut-être un pion passé oui c'est
probable chaque fois et 4 reprend 1,4
oui alors pourquoi évidemment si on
reprend du pillon f ans le 4 est bien
ici c'est une possibilité mais là je
crois simplement le courant des six qui
est pas mal moins bradé 6 par exemple
trois des six est en fait le problème
c'est qu'une structure comme ça l est
pas apte à créer des pions passé oui
peut pas faire d'options passé avec ça
c'est tout bloqué par le fou donc bref
si on ne fait pas toujours passer ça ne
marche plus tout simplement la planète
prend quatre gars il doit prouver avec
le roi c'est vraiment horrible et la
joue quand même fosse de fèves de contre
attaque sur le pion h4
c'est un an mais là ici on savait on
savait que c'était tout le monde le
savait kramnik avait l'air sûr de lui
kasparov était déprimé oui des troubles
on disait c'est nul c'est dur mais
pourquoi c'est nul et bien simplement la
suite est assez logique ou tel parce
qu'ici on va bien comprendre ce qui se
passe on va voir que simplement
mécanique va réussir à échanger des
pions et ensuite à sacrifier son fou
contre les pions qui reste surprend
c'est 5,4 et la c6 contre attaque parce
que la tour attaque le pion h5 et puits
le plan c peut devenir dangereux
attention donc la c6 bronze au monde y
croyait pas toutes façons trois des six
fours à micro-ondes et 610 passe mal et
madeloc le pion fait piquer ses
d'options la voilà et après il ya deux
contre un il va s'incruster un fou
dessus c'est ce qui va se passer et or
alors acheté un kit en prendre cinq fois
f2 bien joué c'est important de
contrôler cette case c5
oui et en plus le fou occupe entre mon
poste ici dans la mesure où il peut pas
être attaquée on voit qu'il est protégé
par les propres options de nom oui c'est
important g43 processus et si la règle
quand vous avez le choix entre prendre
deux pions au début par exemple va les
prendre au coeur du centre ici il y en a
une autre il faut prendre le pion le
plus dangereux
ouais ouais mec là c'est vraiment
l'option ses six sélections sait si
c'est vrai on reprend ses six tours h2
diaries les croit plus toute façon et je
voulais couvrent peu comme ça ouais
c'est vrai ou c5 donc là faut protéger
le plan c4 qui attaque et si ou alors on
s'efforçait à sacrifier la petit coup
étonnant notre ami qu epci gestes
techniques même si ce geste technique
pas mal c'est à dire que là maintenant
les options sont bloqués et la tour est
bloquée au 6 mai donc bref qu'est ce
qu'ils jouent parce que s'ils jouent f4
y ait changé quatre ans prises ouais
s'ils jouent g5 l'option est maintenant
aux prises il n'y a pas de coups
kasparov
il ya plus de coups kasparov le seul
coup qui l'a trouvée c'est de revenir en
h2 éclatement là il revient je devais la
tour pour attaquer le plus risqué
maintenant faible donc la chronique se
serrent faut penser 4 up tempo
voilà et la troche 6 matches 6 food et
stade jacques fould et cinq échecs pas
mal cet échec important très important
bienvenue en plus puisque là
effectivement on peut analyser un peu
les cases il possible pour le roi par
exemple iroise f4 ouais mais on lui
j'aurais fou des six échecs
tranquillo tranquillou si laura montrant
f5 va évidemment on ramassait forme à ce
que plus de trois ans comme dans la
partie 3 on revient un échec
oui et une fois qu'on a chassé le roi
on rigole on fait ce qu'on veut en fait
je veux fawcett qui défendent pions je
crois à peu près c'était à peu près ce
qu'on combler tout à fait ou des quatre
qui est pas mal non plus bref c'était
archi nul ça c'est une possibilité mais
tout fait nul maintenant tout simplement
kasparov il a vu une jour où un f5
à noter qu'il pète hines dans cette
partie seront jouées tellement vite les
premiers coupons est là il restait
encore beaucoup de temps pour être un
lieu qui inquiète beaucoup
alors là kramix auxerre il prend le pian
attention si le foot prend le pion g4
s'est terminée puisque roy et four le
dit dès le début ça fait nul contre
troyes et tours donc il faut pas que
quel soit en flèche ce pur emprise donc
il joue j'essaye normal il joue c'est ça
qu'il faut jouer pour prendre six échecs
où je vais te croire six échecs lui vite
j'essaie marqué ton contre 6 échecs il y
avait probablement ici roi des singes
tout simplement
voilà trois des cinq et après j'ai 5 et
à prêcher 5 il faut cette alerte possède
je pense que ce coup là il pas mal non
plus ah oui si on attaque le pian où on
attaque le pion on veut le prendre
en fait on veut sacrifier un fou sur un
trouve à l'arrêt très difficile et si on
les fout cv tout simplement fou les
quatre échecs et le pian est mort angers
4 et puis la balle assez de leur forme
voilà tout simplement sacrifice de fou
mais c'est nul un truc de fou mais c'est
nul très simplement et fou ça tient
contre la tour donc ici on revient à la
position de la partie
kasparov ici à jouer j'ai cinq
exactement bon roi des cinq nuls
well rade et 5 nuls puisque la cie
kasparov tente de jouer j'ai six matches
et s'ils avaient tout simplement il faut
et quatre échecs échec et on prend
l'avion j'ai six enfants de 6 et
terminer ce pion est mort et six autres
solutions la seule c'est de faire puis
on prend ainsi ses solutions
ils ont leur faire signer aux problèmes
psy mais la voilà probablement tout
échec puisque le roi ne peut pas aller
sur la case g5 de roger à peu près ici
maintenant on va le bloquer
personnellement et pourquoi ici pas un
f4 9 4 c'est possible si oui ou non mais
tout est possible d'en face et ce qui se
passe c'est quand même que la lefp où il
contrôle la casa fuite oui de toute
façon on peut jouer on peut jouer ce
qu'on veut ici strictement des six
échecs on reste le roi on a des échecs
on a vu comment on fait d'une facile
avec roy est fou contre le roi et tout
en allant avec le roi dans le coin
opposé à la couleur du fou exactement
importants comme ça il ya des thèmes de
pâtes et on peut faire mieux donc bien
stéphane alors cette partie donc
kasparov n'est pas passé kasparov n'est
pas passé
il lui reste cinq partis dont il y aura
deux fois les blancs pour essayer de
gagner
on a vu qu'avec les noirs c'est très
très dur de gagner par contre très
facile de perdre très facile de perdre
puisque c'est encore perdre donc restera
encore des chances de perdre une partie
on voit pas on voit toujours pas comment
il peut espérer en gagner une
on a quand même vraiment le sentiment
que kramnik est tout près de devenir le
14e champion du monde d'échecs
c'est vrai il est très près d'autant
plus que kasparov à la conférence de
presse a lui même dit que de toute
évidence son jeu ici n'était pas
brillant ça c'est vrai qu'on s'en était
rendu compte parce que le vrai kasparov
il joue quand même un autre niveau que
ce que gary est en train de produire ici
certes ils jouent bien ils trouvent des
idées il est créatif ici carrie kasparov
non il faut bien le dire donc je le jeu
qui le montre ici et pas très fort mais
la cicas maroc perd c'est vraiment la
paix la fin d'une ère c'est pas comme
âge qui perdu c'est qu'il n'est plus
champion du monde s'il veut jouer jouer
encore pour le titre il va falloir qu'il
joue les qualifications s'il y en a oui
parce que crâne qui peut rester chez un
peu le monde pendant 33 80 s'il ya pas
de quoi il peut faire un match peut-être
contre son adversaire l'adversaire ou
son choix par willy éventuellement non
mais bon c'est plus mais sérieusement là
il reste s'intéressa pose de gros
problèmes à kasparov
il reste cinq parties mais comment
kasparov peut s'en sortir et bien là il
va falloir qu'ils jouent à fond et on
espère enfin moi j'espère que kasparov
va jouer l'estonienne samedi avec les
noirs parce qu'on se rappelle que c'est
quand même avec cette défense là qu'il
avait posé de gros problèmes à karpov
on sait que l'estonienne jouit pas d'une
grosse réputation
ces derniers temps mais c'est peut-être
sa seule opportunité sa seule chance de
sortir une grosse estonienne avec une
nouveauté théorique qui pourrait battre
en brèche un petit peu les derniers
développements des blancs donc peut-être
que kasparov après une estonienne ça
vous le saurez en revenant nous voir
pour le direct de samedi stéphane à 16
heures heure française donc la 12e
partie de ce match d'exception à noter
que la troisième est à venir le chiffre
13 c'est le chiffre porte bonheur de
garry kasparov oui qu'en fait il peut
bénéficier peut-être de ce chiffre porte
bonheur pour ne gagne qu'une seule
partie rappelons qu'en cas de 8,8 safra
match nul oui s'il gagne dimanche s'il a
encore une chance il reste trois parties
c'est plus chaud mais la voilà donc tout
est encore possible et on vous a on vous
attend à 16 heures heure française
samedi prochain pour le direct